Facebook's designed decision rather to
ban several high-profile extremists from
Facebook and Instagram is drawing both
praise and outrage Facebook which owns
Instagram cited its policies against
allowing dangerous individuals and
organizations on its site in banning
people like Alex Jones and Milo you
nopales CBS News contributor and wired
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson is
here with the social media Giants
decision Nick good morning good morning
the band's effect mostly far-right
figures and while it's not clear exactly
what triggered the move now Facebook has
faced intense criticism for years for
not doing enough to curb hate speech and
misinformation on its site they just ban
me they just defamed us ly right-wing
personality Alex Jones lashed out
Thursday after Facebook to banned him
and his website Infowars for years
Jones spread conspiracy theories online
including claims that the Newtown school
shooting was staged Sandy Hook is a
synthetic completely fake with actors
yesterday Facebook and Instagram bans
Jones Nation of Islam leader Louis
Farrakhan and all tripe personalities
Milo u Nautilus and Laura Loomer all of
whom have used the site to spread
anti-semitic or anti-muslim content
Facebook did not provide specific
examples Paul Joseph Watson an editor
Infowars who was also banned says he
broke none of the platform's rules this
is punishment
this is a political purge this has
nothing to do with hey the company's
official policy bans hate speech that
fosters quote intimidation and exclusion
and a facebook spokesman says the site
has always banned pages that promote or
engage in violence and hate regardless
of ideology the company has long
struggled with the spread of hate
last week after the synagogue shooting
near San Diego white supremacist
expressed support on a Facebook page
linked to the alleged shooter Facebook
later took the page down Ben Scott is an
expert in tech policy it does raise the
question how are they defining who gets
banned and who doesn't
Scott says Facebook's crackdown is a
major shift in the way the company
addresses the content they publish they
are owning responsibility for the
content on the platform and that is a
huge move and one that they have
resisted for a long time critics say
Facebook's move censors free speech
while others say it doesn't go far
enough
the ban comes at a time when Facebook
has been in a PR nightmare over its
privacy issues this is such a tricky
question it is very tricky who gets to
decide what is and what is not offensive
Facebook gets to decide they set
policies and they run their algorithms
and then they make a choice wellin but
Nick it even brings up the question when
you look at when you look at for example
Alex Jones who's spreading you know
essentially you know his theory with no
facts really behind it I mean how do you
make a judgement there it's really hard
and there's a balance and there's a
balance basically between free speech
and safety and for most of its history
Facebook has said we're gonna prioritize
free speech no we're a neutral platform
people can do what they want then
they've seen what's happened and over
the last couple years there's been this
realization at Facebook wait we're not
just a platform we can actually cause
real harm in society and then in the
last couple of weeks as we've seen mass
murder live streamed on Facebook you can
see why they would shift and there'd be
less free speech and more about
promoting safety and that's what's
happened people are allowed to change
their mind and change their policies for
the better for the better of their
platform in their company no data is
what I think is happening here Thank You
Nick